[Music]
last week on Survivor game-changers
castaway Jeff Varner was sent home after
outing fellow castaway
Zeke Smith there is deception here why
haven't you told anyone you're
transgender
the shocking TV moment has since gone
viral and now Varner is dealing with the
repercussions of his actions I love him
I feel for him and I'll do whatever I
can in the future to help him if you'll
let me
on Saturday Varner confirmed to et he
was fired from his job at Allen Tate
real estate in North Carolina the 51
year old realtor says he's devastated
over it
explaining quote it was an ugly day my
former boss told me that I was in a news
story they wanted nothing to do with on
Sunday Varner's former employer spoke
out about the decision to let him go
the company's CEO Pat Riley told ET in a
statement the Allen Tate companies were
built on core values of honesty
integrity and respect those fundamental
beliefs led us to end our relationship
with mr. Varner et spoke with Varner
after the incident aired last week he
said he and Smith have been in therapy
and hopes that they can both move
forward
I feel like now the healing can begin
not only for me but hopefully for Zeke
and hopefully for trans people across
the world
[Music]
you